maps are data structures that store key
value pairs in JavaScript objects are
maps maps provide rapid lookup of stored
items based on key values and they're
very common in useful data structures in
this video I will show you how to
implement a map in JavaScript to give a
better understanding of how they work
however normally you would never need to
write your own map data structure in
JavaScript because objects provide a
very efficient map structure also later
in the video I will talk about the map
object that was introduced in es6 this
has some benefits over using a standard
object as a map this is a visual
representation of a map so you have
these keys that in this case are all
months and then you have the values
which are what the keys correspond to
when you're using a map first you would
enter all these key and key value pairs
and then later you may want to look up a
value so you would look up the August
key and then we give you out this value
37.3 now let's look at the code for how
you could implement a map in JavaScript
so we have my map equals function and
you're gonna keep track of two things
the collection which is all the things
in the map and then the count so the
number of items that you have we have
the size method where we return this
count to get the size of the map then to
set that means just that you're going to
add something so you pass in a key and a
value and then we're just going to set
that key and the value into the
collection and we're gonna update the
count and then fur has that just means
you're gonna check if the map has that
key and you're gonna return key in this
dot collection the in operator returns
true if the specified property is in the
specified object so now we have yet
where we're going to pass in the key and
we're going to get the value we have a
ternary operator here so if the key is
in this collection that's true
we're gonna return the key it's this
first section and then else we are going
to return null then we're going to be
able to delete an item in the
you just passing the key and if the keys
and the collection again we're going to
delete that key and you're going to
decrement the count so we have one less
and the values function here is where
we're going to return an array of all
the values in the map so we just have a
for loop where we push each item into
the array and then if there's more than
zero items we're gonna return that array
or we're gonna return null and then the
clear method you are just going to clear
all the items from the map and then
we're going to set the item the count to
zero okay let's see a quick example of
using the map oh and let's change this
to map here and we'll run that okay you
can see we created a new map we added
some items here what we have the keys
and the values key in value and then
here we're gonna get the value socially
with that key and you can see on the
console it's ten and then we're gonna
check the size it's four and then we're
going to output all the values in the
map to an array now I'm gonna talk a
little bit about the es6 map object
objects are similar to maps in that they
both let you set keys to values retrieve
those values delete keys and detect
whether something is stored at a key but
there are some differences between
objects and es6 Maps an object has a
prototype so there are default keys and
a map that could collide with your keys
if you're not careful the keys of an
object can only be strings or symbols
but keys for a map can be any value
including functions objects numbers
boolean or even not a number you can get
the size of a map easily with the size
property well this as an object must be
determined manually you're immediately
gonna you want to use a map if you have
a collection so let's see an example of
using in es6 map
now this map is gonna have all the
functions I showed below but it's also
going to have a few more so we're gonna
be able to do map to dot has to see if
it that has a certain value in the map
we're also going to be able to do the
entries method this is going to return
an array of all the keys in the map the
the values method returns all the values
in the map and the entries returns all
the keys in the map okay and I just put
in some more code here just to show some
of the things that you can do with the
map object and creating two variables
this key object is just an empty object
key funk is just an empty function and
then down here you can see you can set
strings to values but you can also set
these objects objects can be a key you
can set that to a value this function
can be a key you can set that to a value
and you can even use not a number as a
key and set that to a value we have the
size that we've shown before on the
other map and then here we can get the
values of what we added above help but
first this is the extra social an equal
sign not a minus sign so it should be
let map to equal new map and then the
only other thing I need to change is
that there should not be parentheses
after the size here and my custom map a
function above I didn't need parentheses
but here I don't precise is a is a
property and not a method so let's try
running that okay you can see I logged
the size four we have four items here
and then I was able to get all these
values up here well that's map thanks
for watching my name is beau Carnes
don't forget to subscribe and remember
use your code for good